transcriptomics one is an introductory
course on RNA seek in this course we
will cover key concepts needed to
understand the analysis of gene
expression data to successfully complete
this course you will need a basic
knowledge of selling molecular biology
you will also benefit from taking the
introduction to bioinformatics course we
have available on edu T bio info site
the course is an introduction to
next-generation sequencing and the
topics to be covered include both the
quantitative and qualitative analysis of
RNA samples data preparation using
next-generation sequencing as well as
preparation of the table of expression
from raw fast queue files we will also
touch on visualization of high
dimensional data using principal
component analysis the course features
seven full-length lectures two quizzes
for assessment and provides users with a
certificate upon completion of the
6-hour track the year 2020 marks a 70
year mark since the discovery of the
structure and function of the DNA
molecule it took almost 50 years from
that time to sequence the first human
genome but soon after the technology
developed evolved rapidly by 2015 the
1000 genome project brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
in 2018 over 100,000 whole genomes were
sequenced today there is an ever
increasing number of genomic
transcriptomics proteomics and made a
genomic data sets that are available to
describe subcellular processes with
highly detailed digital data the Onix
technologies are used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cells of an organism of comics data
can be generated using NGS or what is
also known as high-throughput sequencing
the data can show detailed information
about genomic variants at the genomic
regulation as well as gene and isoform
expression this online course is built
to provide a complete overview of the
biological background key terminology
and basic concepts you will need in
order to start analyzing RNA seek data
from a deeper review of the central
dogma of molecular biology we will go
through a background of how data works
and what it represents after this review
we will apply this understanding to
learn about the logic of building an RNA
seek pipeline
in the review of the biology behind RNA
seek we will talk about transcription
and how that process takes place in the
cell in this lesson we will also learn
about alternative splicing and various
gene isoforms produced as a result of
the transcription process there are many
steps in the process of converting a DNA
sequence into a protein product in this
course we will focus on the brief
outline of transcription giving special
attention to the steps you should keep
in mind as you study transcriptomics
data the process of transcription kicks
off with RNA polymerase adding
complementary nucleotides to a DNA
template strand various proteins bind to
the polyadenylation site at the three
prime end of the pre mRNA molecule next
a cap and tail are added to the
respective five Prime and three prime
ends non-coding introns are removed and
the exons are joined together finally
the five prime cap is recognized by a
nuclear pore complex signaling the
export of mRNA from the nucleus to the
cytosol we will also learn about the
sequencing process transcriptome
sequencing is a major advance in the
study of gene expression because it
allows a snapshot of the whole
transcriptome rather than a
predetermined subset of genes to study
this data we will learn about processing
pipelines that turn raw reads into
structured data ready for analysis
sequencing data is stored in several
different file formats for example fast
queue files provide us with reads from
the sequencer it is a text-based file
format that's towards nucleotide
sequences of reads and quality scores
for each letter last-day is a text-based
file format representing DNA and protein
sequences typically this is the
reference file for the genome then we
have the genome transfer format for GTF
file which contains genome annotation
for example the GTF will store the start
and end of each genomic element exon as
a form and gene to process next
generation sequencing data we must first
map reads onto the reference genome to
do so we have to know where on the
genome we have exons this information is
in the GTF file then we can take
sequences from the fast queue file where
we have short reads to align some
annotated position on the
no the genome reference gives us
information on where the gene is located
and what exons are on that gene then as
different isoforms are created from the
single gene reference different reads
are mapped onto specific exons as you
can see from this GTF file example on
chromosome 15 we have an exon that
starts and ends at a specific place and
belongs to a given gene and transcript
ID etc to understand why other steps are
needed in the rna-seq analysis pipeline
let's look at the expression of genes
and how data can be used to study this
this is the reference genome where you
have gene a gene B and gene C not
everything is transcribed for example
gene a and gene C are transcribed but
gene B is not the product is RNA which
gets shattered into pieces of cDNA there
are adapters that are attached to the
beginning in the end of each fragment
this nucleotide information is amplified
using PCR and is then only read by the
sequencer and this is where our analysis
steps start RNA pipelines typically
include three main steps pre-processing
mapping and quantification
pre-processing is needed to clean up our
data by removing the adapters trimming
some of the reads and removing the PCR
duplicates this is important because PCR
amplification is not uniform across all
reads then we take up the cleaned up
read sequences and map them on to a
reference using the fast a file for the
sequences of the genome and the GTF file
for annotation based on the quality of
annotation we can use the various
strategies for mapping once a step is
complete we have to quantify expression
levels and give each expressed element a
number to help remember this information
when building our pipeline but we use a
specifically designed interactive
platform for practical exercises the
platform's color coded in helps
establish a logical connection between
the theoretical aspects of data analysis
methods and the practical steps needed
to achieve a biologically interpretable
result the course will also explain the
pipeline results from raw read sequences
we now have structured data where
columns are sample name
and rose our gene and isoform IDs in in
Samba format inside each cell we will
find the quantified expression level
this course is part of the
transcriptomics series that will cover
other important aspects of RNA seek
processing analysis and biological
interpretation of gene expression the
online courses are supplemented by
additional resources we provide to our
dynamic bioinformatics community these
include regular online webinars project
examples and training programs we
regularly review the course content to
make sure we keep the information
up-to-date and user-friendly thousands
of students faculty and researchers from
around the globe are successfully using
these resources to learn bioinformatics
as well as apply these analysis tools to
various projects and biomedical studies
agriculture and biotechnology